holy bunco's kids look out the keep it
moving tour is adding new dates
we're coming to a city near you
come and see us some stand-up and we
play ayg at the end of the show with the
crowd we answer your garbage questions
we've got some trash so far but i know i
know
there's deeper garbage out there around
the country oh yeah so come on out and
see us kippy tell them what they need to
know oh baby we're all over the place
tejas baby
uh september 21st will be in san antonio
texas september 22nd we'll be in houston
texas september 23rd through the 25th
austin texas for the moon tower comedy
festival and i ain't done yet august
26th will be at fort dallas fort worth
texas what then we're bringing it back
to long island baby what and all uh
september 30th and then we're coming
home the boys are the chickens are
coming home to roost baby
october 27th we're gonna be in
philadelphia pennsylvania and then back
down to tejas uh november 5th through
the 7th for skankfest south get those
tickets the link will be in the
description welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage sure is the little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they grew up to be
classy but they're just a big old piece
of trash oh yeah i'm your host stage
foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at aunt tooty's basement
she's all excited for the eggles for the
eagles coming up this season the birds a
little bit of a problem what's that she
didn't realize about the quarterback
switch she got a carson wentz tattoo the
other day
she did that might be the first one that
actually got me
[ __ ] 74 episodes in you finally got
me my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the ceo of ru
garbage he's international businessman
he is not to be trifled with in the
boardroom i can tell you that or the
bedroom do me a favor give me a nice big
round of applause for kevin james ryan
everybody gang happy to be here as
always thanks for tuning in please make
sure you subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are true true the [ __ ]
roof baby and then i would be an [ __ ]
if i didn't bring up that wonderful
website www greatest of all stop patrons
it's www.patreon.com
ru garbage
cooking over there baby
again those numbers are true to roof
through the atmosphere baby uh you can
sign up you get bonus episodes at ayg
episodes of hard feelings there's a
whole nother pod we do live streams uh
with our top tier guests it's a [ __ ]
good time get involved yes sir and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's up
dudes hey t-bone i'm doing great i'm
excited to be here we got a real car guy
in here he's going to find out i don't
have a license he's going to lose all
respect
i'll tell you what we got we got a
little [ __ ] star power in here today
let me tell you this gang we could not
be more excited to have our incredibly
and i mean incredibly special guest here
with us today for the first time in
studio he is an extremely funny
extremely successful
up
actor and podcaster do yourself a favor
as i read off these credits pull
yourself a cup of coffee and make it a
large
because it's gonna take a minute now
these this isn't even all of them that's
the crazy thing we're gonna go through
them ready caroline in the city all
right 19 episodes of the job law and
order king of queens three different
episodes three different characters no
big deal
very versatile definitely maybe paul
blart mall cops smash hit
ugly betty here we go 50 episodes of the
fx hit rescue me
on top of that 20 episodes what's that
nurse jackie jesus 20 apps kevin can
wait
criminal minds ncis little italy now we
go to the stand-up portion of the
credits
we got the late show with james corden
premium blend what late show with david
letterman he's got his own comedy
central presents the rosie o'donnell
show the late show craig ferguson
how far back are you going
went to the smithsonian for this one the
sears portrait studio
he's done many many talkies the late
show with craig ferguson rachel ray the
tonight show with jay leno the tonight
show with jimmy fallon wtf with mark
mallon hell's kitchen
67 episodes of top gear usa he has an
amazing special called funny asl and of
course the adam ferrara podcast but the
big question about his mind today is he
garbage if he is you can write a check
and get out of it
ladies and gentlemen give it up for mr
adam ferrara
holy [ __ ] thank you so much damn wow
you think it'd be more money you really
would
that's funny because you talked to us
when you were like oh have you done that
we haven't done anything oh yeah and
then we got i look at this i'm holy [ __ ]
stop it but you were reading tv
you guys are killing it thank you
[Laughter]
no you guys are first of all i am
honored to be i'm a big fan of the show
as you know because i've had both of you
guys yeah thank you
separately
and toby i'm gonna have you on i heard
there's no driver's license so we'll
have to send a car
but yeah you guys uh i'm i'm really
honored to be you're doing a great job
and i really enjoyed it like i said when
you were on my show i got a lot of
comments about the commonality of
everything oh i appreciate that again it
was cool yeah it was a good time this is
so old school man you know you know gee
it's it's unbelievable yeah it's fun
it's it's nice to do you know do that we
talked cause you were a theater school
yeah and acting and stuff yeah so you
know it's like now you can you can't
just be a stand-up you got to be a
partner you got to be doing something
you got to do everything great now i'm a
[ __ ] renaissance man i got to come up
i got to come up with a flying machine
i want da vinci to go go to my patreon
and make a [ __ ] fly
did we mention the vegan bakery that he
has downtown in l.a folks
what is the uh what is the origin story
of adam ferrari i know you're a queen i
was born in hillcrest in jamaica um and
we moved out uh my father my father was
in the plumbing business okay my
grandfather and that's right we talked
about this on yours yes
yeah yeah
no
dutch listen to my accent
yeah italians and my my uncle and my uh
my father worked for my grandfather in
plumbing business in queens okay uh the
neighborhood was changing and my father
says we're getting the helani we're
going out to the island guys
i was a baby boys i don't even remember
that was it the everybody the island
yeah the island just meant you know why
you know this is like tumbleweeds and
[ __ ] there's nothing the original
suburbs yeah so we moved out they bought
the house and i think we talked about
this my father actually built the house
that's great what yeah well he he
modified it and he didn't go to school
for this stuff they just self-taught
guys yeah yeah yeah you're dead too yeah
yeah for sure yeah so one day i came
home and my father off school is in a
bulldozer
we had a corner lot and he's cutting a
circular drum i remember this that's the
most italian [ __ ] i've ever heard in my
life you're caught in your own circus
yeah italians don't like the reverse
they're like
where are you gonna put the fountain
kippy
we're gonna put the fountains a couple
of lion statues
so he's on a bulldozer and i said pop
how did you learn how to do this i
rented it which is what we're doing
today and he cut the circular driveway
he would just do it man that's the thing
that that amazes me there was no
fear there was nothing there was just
wow
i can't even hang blinds in my apartment
yeah we talk about that all the time the
difference in generations of like you
know with us how not men we are compared
to like our parents and grandparents
yeah so who who came over was it
here's my thing i think my my nonna
which is my great-grandmother on my
mother's side i think was from the old
country she didn't speak english she had
two teeth and we're pretty sure she was
a cocaine addict because she sounds like
a nice lady yeah oh she was she cooked
for you all day because she didn't sleep
oh of course she was there something
about older like grandmothers when they
hit like 80 they just never sleep
they're just up i think she was
chemically enhanced yeah sure she had
remember the snuff that they were yeah
yeah yeah tobacco yeah so she would send
my grandfather who drove a fruit truck
in queens down to the docks to pick up
this stuff i'm like why don't you go to
[ __ ] stocks
yeah to the docks and she came back and
got and she and when she didn't get it
she was angry yeah so i kind of figured
she was up and the teeth were gone so
she had meth mouth
[Laughter]
mouth in the 20s yeah all hopped up on
cranky talking about an o.g
so i that was my mother's side of the
family so i think my mother's mother was
born here okay my father's family was
here for a little bit longer and so his
father had a successful plumbing
business yeah you know a little plumbing
business in queens and then my uncle
michael louis my father worked for him
but my father wanted to be like creative
and stuff you know it's like he just
didn't want to do the plumbing i wanted
to do like kitchens and bathrooms and
that's how we design stuff and let's be
honest boys i can do plumbing i can't do
it well yeah i know but [ __ ] don't go
uphill damn now you know it yeah yeah so
i couldn't do any of that [ __ ] no
no i'm terrible with that well you
worked for your dad yeah plus it depends
what you're doing i mean if it's like
pvc or whatever yeah
yeah they call it throw and go you just
like glue and [ __ ] in primer and that's
it i had to pee on the floor
i was mainly the digging guy they were
like here dig this whole six years oh i
was the same we'll come in and do work
for 20 minutes and then you fill it back
in yeah i was the rip out guy because
you can't really break anything sure
yeah and i load into trucks and then um
i would i would when i got my license
was great because he's not the you i
could drive so i could go and run [ __ ]
back and forth
this this is how i think we talked about
it yeah that was my dream when i was
like 14. i was like wait till i get my
license yeah i'll be driving that pickup
truck oh running
bucks an hour that's
this is how garbage we were we had a uh
a 70 coupe deville my mother had a
cadillac uh and she flicked a cigarette
out the window
we thought she flicked a cigarette out
the window came around the back there's
benson and hedges
landed in the back seat we wake up the
next day and there's smoke just coming
out of the back who's in the back seat
of the car it's like black smoke like oh
we have a pope
coming out of the car and so my father
ripped the back seat out and we figured
we can get lengths of pipe in it a half
inch pipe yeah we gotta run those
lengths to jobs right so we could get
him in the trunk going through the uh
it goes right up to the desk
yeah that's what we did
and my and i took my driver's test in
that car
with three lengths of copper
the guy sitting in the car like this my
father told me before i went up there he
goes don't slam on the brakes because
the torch is going to hit you in the
back of the head
and they'll probably fail you i got a
new toilet seat in there don't [ __ ] it
up yeah all right so we're in long
island yeah brothers and sisters two
brothers they're both in the restaurant
business nice older younger i'm the
oldest the two younger brothers how
young are we talking uh year and a half
and five years all right so you you
three there's just the animals together
right you're not close enough what
happened in our house was um because of
the restaurant business and being a
stand-up
our at midnight there's a pot of sauce
on there's neighbors are coming up so
our house was the house to be in okay so
at night the house would come alive so
everybody would come over so it was a
nice way to grow up because you had all
the family you know a lot of [ __ ] going
on yeah there was always something going
on in the house there was always food
there was always a game on it was always
someone sleeping on the couch and as
soon as you turn the channel i'm
watching yeah what are you doing
so you guys had you said your uncle
louise so you had extended family all
around you did they move out to the
burbs as well yeah they were out my uh
my uncle frank my godfather was in um
i was in hicksville on long island okay
we all came out to long island everybody
packed up and moved to the island and
everyone and christmas was great because
my father was the youngest so all the
all the older cousins came over and okay
there were always people in the house
mike my uncle frank worked for united
airlines
and uh they were throwing out they had a
a 14-foot christmas tree in the uh like
the halls the jfk right
in the tournament terminal wait a minute
it was white
italians i've always been on record
italians love a white christmas tree
they do he take the christmas tree oh
yeah and put it in his house oh no he
put the top half in his house oh my god
bottom half of his cousins no bottom
half in our house
so yeah we got the bottom half so you
had a you had a you had a half a
christmas hedge yeah it didn't come to a
point yeah so yeah so we had a white
christmas tree put a christmas tree yeah
split a christmas tree what a free
christmas tree that he stole from jfk
i'm pretty sure red bows it was the most
gandaloon [ __ ] i love that word
scorsese would walk in my house and go
too much too much
no one's going to believe it
tomatoes are hanging instead of lights
cheese
salami and cheese are hanging for
santa's coming make him a panini
uh but your dad i assume your dad did
well you guys grew up pretty good yeah
we grew up we grew up pretty good we uh
we we didn't
want for anything or we didn't you know
what we didn't know we didn't have sure
make sense
and and then but yeah there was always
there was always a he always listened he
would yell a lot a
most plumbers are like that yeah yelling
and a lot of work ethic but he would
always take the time to try and teach
you something and then give you a chore
you know
listen you listen to somebody else you
made someone else's [ __ ] mistake and
i gotta pay for it all right that's what
you do and then after it's over you move
on and don't do it again there you go
let's take out the goblins
yeah yeah
yeah yeah did he want you did he when
did your brothers get into the
restaurant business and did your dad
want you guys to follow yeah in the
family business yeah here's the thing
that happened i think my father was
always disappointed nobody went into his
business because it was a good business
yeah that was made money but i don't
have the mechanical ability you know we
talked about it i don't you know i i
love cars i got i got my love of cars
for my dad because he could fix anything
so one day i'm trying i'm working on the
car right he's standing in the doorway
smoking a lucky just looking at me i can
feel him no filter no filter
the filter's banned for your phone
yeah this is natural indians grow this
so he's sitting there smoking a lucky
and their wrenches have fallen
blood spurting oils dripping my father
came over took a drag of his cigarette
put his hand on my shoulder son look
you're gonna have to get a job and
you're gonna have to work at something
the rest of your life
they're saying that ain't it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
learn how to type or something buddy so
i'm crushed so i and i i'm still to this
day couldn't be like my dad cut to i get
out of school he sent me to school he
says you're going to college where'd you
go where'd you go marist college in
poughkeepsie marina yeah
no
i got out doing the ballerina i got out
doing a 2-2 baby that was it
just out i wasn't staying longer than i
had to but i was just i came home every
weekend and worked i worked at the walt
whitman fence company i drove a forklift
okay i made deliveries
so um
he came to see me do stand-up when i got
out of college so you didn't start
standing up until you got out of cu i
got out of college with four years did
four years did four years get out of
college i did four years i got out
that's literally his understanding of he
did all four years old
holy [ __ ] look at the brain on him
that's impressive for me man yeah i made
it about 18 months yeah
that was two summers in there
but when i got out he came to see me do
stand up for the first time okay because
i made the mistake of telling my mother
my mother is the original twitter it
just goes all over the freaking name
sure yeah so i told you
those old timers all right it goes they
all came out to the club and i so i did
i had material but you know i had a
cousin say
be funny and i just made fun of him for
five minutes before you know it it's
over yeah so my father saw me do that i
walked to the shop the next day because
i had to go to work
he looked at me
never looked at me like that before and
i said i i want to give this a try pop
and again with the lucky you do it now
because you do it now before your life
gets complicated damn smart that's a
wise [ __ ] story
yeah and then that then he threatens you
you better give it everything you've got
sure yeah don't embarrass me otherwise
now go cut the grass yeah
yeah every every life everything yeah
every life lesson ends with that yeah
even when you're 40s like now go cut the
grass yeah that's it i'll go find my dad
i live
if you get older like the problems get
more complex sure and and the advice
gets short and the chores get bigger
she's pregnant i don't love her but i
want to do the right thing [ __ ] happens
taught a roof
cut a roof paint the garage you'll feel
better
you'll be all right and that was it and
then from there you were on your way
yeah i did my first open mic and you
know what saved me or what allowed me to
work more in comedy i had a car
yeah that's big but i had a car yeah i
was on long island what are we talking
what year are we talking about my first
time was july 13th 1988 east side comedy
club wednesday night man wednesday night
old yeah that's it baby we did i was
like because that's the first time i
ever felt like okay i belong here uh-huh
you know like you know when you hit a
golf ball right yeah sure that's the i
was like all right something just
happened yeah of course i don't know
what it is yeah so i had a car and i had
a work ethic
so i would hustle i would pick up the
comics when the improv was open uh-huh i
would pick up the comics here and we'd
drive to these shitty gigs in
connecticut these bar gigs yeah
i loved when i got a gig and it said
comedy club i'm like oh they know what's
coming yeah i'm not annoying yeah it's
not gonna be a [ __ ] sneak attack yeah
hey surprise we're turning the game off
comedy show
[Applause]
i did it i did it one time me and chris
cotton did a show in front of an eagles
playoff game on a projector in between
commercials oh my god in jersey i did
one at a bowling alley next to the papa
shot basketball
you can't compete with papa now i don't
care you're a funny guy but i love a
good papa shot they didn't turn it off
of course
of course i'm there like dogs are funny
three pointers frankie
frankie i got a 27 this guy's all right
who are we rolling around with around
this time this time i start there was a
little community on long island excuse
me it was me um kevin james right gary
valentine okay uh rock rubin who's now
was the executive producer of uh kevin
can wait okay and um
and the king queens so those were the
four that's the squad yeah that would be
four of those pretty good [ __ ] squad
i gotta say that ain't bad we're gonna
sit here tall i mean that's a [ __ ]
that's the tightest squad i've heard but
we were
the east side comedy club we painted a
uh a strike zone on the back in the
parking lot and we would play wiffle
ball during the day nice and then we'd
write jokes and then try and bozos oh
yeah yeah let's go play wiffle ball on
the back
[Laughter]
and then write jokes yeah and then how
long did you stay
so did you guys
stay in long island or how are you going
into the city no i never moved to the
city really no i never i so
that's like that's a big step moving
into the city that's what saturday night
fever you gotta get exactly you gotta
get across the bridge you're getting
across that water from somebody from
long island we're doing yeah
i'm bridging channel but this could wash
you off
campystamps.comstamps.com i'll say it
one more
hit em stamps.com
let's go we use them we love them we use
them to send out all the cards we did it
easy peasy printed them out packed them
up walked to the post office dropped
them off we rather in two seconds you do
not want to waste time hanging around
the post office you want to get in and
get out and stamps.com can help kippy
straighten these bozos out where i've
been trying for months stamps.com baby
simply use your computer they're print
official i ain't talking fake i'm
talking official us postage 24 7 and you
might be thinking for some letters for
some packages for any class of mail
certain places nope any letter any
package any class of mail anywhere you
want to send it once your mail is ready
you can you you can schedule a pickup
they'll come pick it up for you wait
really i swear to god so you don't have
to go to the post office at all at all
stamps.com like the big man said you'll
get discounts up to 40 off post office
rates and 66 percent off ups shipping
right now that's banco not to mention
stamps.com is a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters what are
we doing no brainer over here save the
time and money um stop wasting time by
going to the post office go to
stamps.com instead there's no risk with
our promo code garbage you'll get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
wow kicker no long-term commitments or
contracts you don't like it you use it
you don't use whatever but you're gonna
love it i'm telling you you're gonna
love it one more time stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in garbage.stamps.com
promo code garbage stamps.com never go
to the post office again do it
now back to the show holy [ __ ] no i did
i never moved into the city kevin and i
got an apartment down by the uh down by
the uh train station in huntington okay
but we were also doing a row because
none of us had enough
stand up time to do full college gigs
right but we could improv so we did the
improv game so we would both do 20
minutes of stand up each that was 40.
and in 20 minutes of you know like
improv
participation so we had a little show
that we could sell and
and do um
art that's awesome we got a similar
thing yeah that's kind of what we do
any questions yeah
where are you from again sarah you still
are still a dentist
i got t-bone to hook up the projector
yeah what was that like when you what
was the what was where would your pop
take you guys on vacation what would you
guys do lake george new york really yeah
that's nice that's right real nice okay
so you leave you don't understand
through you know it's beautiful you're
honest through such a [ __ ] new york
story yeah he's insane we had his little
boat and we pulled it with a cadillac
that catalyst god you are like
aggressively italian oh god pulling a
boat with a cattle cattle
boat landing where you where you where
you parked the car there's trucks
there's suburbans and there's there's a
77 fleetwood broom right that's our car
it's it it's it's like ups brown with a
trailer hitch on the back
yeah so you guys would go up there they
go up there and it was uh we had the
boat and you camp on the islands and we
had because my father was in kitchens
and bathrooms we had a running water
he built this little cabinet thing that
came right up out of the boat with a
pump and he would drain because you
could drain it right off right right
into the ground and you just run the
water
and you would and he would uh we had a
toilet in the boat my father was like
i'm not [ __ ] in a house
yeah yeah [ __ ] bear i'm not [ __ ]
out he put plumbing in the pool how are
you going to make the sauce in the boat
[Laughter]
oh that's my mother is trying to cook
ziti on a barbecue with tin foil oh my
god she's cooked she's heating i've
never heard of hot dogs what's going on
oh cooking pasta everything all the
relatives are coming up i got my my
uncles are coming up i got one uncle
who's fishing off the dock in a
three-piece suit
he's got a tommy gun and a cigar
[Laughter]
toby i hope i don't catch a witness
that's a fun party till elliot ness
shows up yeah a three-piece suit that's
yeah
but that was that was the big vacation
was lake george new york you camp on an
island did you guys ever go anywhere
else disney world anything like that
went to disney world once did you
because my my grandfather we didn't know
my grandfather was sick and he was down
florida so that's why we went nice uh so
we went down once and then that was it
okay and we drove oh yeah what yeah
summer in the summer and the plumbing
with the plumbing stuff in there before
this before i think
yeah we drove down uh you're sitting at
copper pipe for 18 years and i remember
thinking of myself south of the border
how [ __ ] far away oh my god when
you're a kid and you drive more than
three hours you're like where are we
going mars yeah holy [ __ ] and you can
get and all the north carolina you could
get fireworks and pecans
that was it can we get now all the nuts
you want nothing that blows up
so that we did that and then the host
phone it was a host farm in pennsylvania
one of those resort things yeah sure
yeah we went there once in a while okay
so eventually your grandfather they
moved down to florida they went to
florida this is like the
the classic italian-american migration
story yeah [ __ ] queens to long island
grandfather moves down to florida
that's what they're doing
pope says we can go we got the blessing
i wanted to ask you this dad
in your house yeah was there
three pictures of three different people
like was there
was there like the kennedy picture
no no there was who was it pope pius
okay sinatra of course yeah sinatra pope
pius is there in a row right yeah that
was and it was i i was only two was it
pope pius sinatra chef boyardee
the little caesars guy
pavarotti dude the picture of sinatra
that is so [ __ ] the one with the
hanging that the mike and i happen to
know his microphone is a telefunken u-47
which was the same one jim morrison the
one who's hanging with the hat
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so the irish
version of that is it kennedy kennedy
the pope everybody does the pope
and then uh
it would be like some notre dame coach
it would be like yeah i'd be like newt
rodney or something like that
meanwhile no pictures of the kids
anywhere yeah and they were always going
it was going up the stairs oh all the
pictures going up just going up
that's garbage we had a red red blood
red rug
with the stucco on the wall so you'd
walk by i can smell that yeah yeah i can
smell it yeah dark this dark green
furniture and i was like ah this is like
this is caesar's palace casino
we might as well have a cigarette girl
in the kitchen
shoot a little bit of craps you know
what i mean yeah anybody see my ass
she's in the kino bar you want to go
talk to her that was the big thing for
them like after when i got started going
on the road
uh and my brothers went to college and
they got out right bake went to atlantic
city every other [ __ ] weekend they go
to olympics yeah they go down here they
sent the plane
for my my dad what yeah they were
gamblers they sent the
the plane from to where republic airport
on long island really and you fly down
atlantic city and then you piss away my
inheritance
[Laughter]
what was their game my father like my
father liked the uh the poker machines
he don't talk to nobody sure because i'm
not sitting on a blackjack table because
some idiot doesn't hit on i'm not doing
this yeah so he liked the poker machines
my mother liked the the slots and the
poker machines but then the crap table
was that's where i got it what year are
we talking where they're doing this
would you well uh
i moved to l.a in 93 okay so i would say
from 90 until my dad got ill okay he was
a good solid 20 years ago he was god
that's all yeah he was going yeah and he
would ev everything in my house it sees
his palace the robes the shampoos
everything matches everything ash trays
everything happens
all over the place because they sent the
gift baskets and they brought them home
and nobody drank my father didn't drink
he was a diabetic he didn't drink it
bring a champagne oh my god that's so
funny
so the red carpet in the house yeah what
else are we talking about in there
plastic on the on the no no we weren't
that that that that that we got the
plastic on there we had the copper pots
on the cup
and for some reason chickens were big in
the kitchen i don't know why they had
chickens on [ __ ] yeah yeah that picture
yeah yeah 100 yeah so we had that um and
we
we had the food was always weird because
i think we talked about the big thing
that we could get as a treat remember
the variety packs that are little
cereals oh my god oh my god
yeah yeah they only get hotels oh that
was like christmas and when we would
camp on the islands my father we would
eat it out of the bowl he took out he
had his bayonet he got from the army he
go hey we're gonna have breakfast
and do it right in the box cut the bowl
open put the milk in you eat it with a
spoon outside like like i'm biv whacking
with the great santina
oh yeah so we had that we had um the car
was always had a cadillac where was a
cadillac and a plumbing truck i always
had a cadillac and a plug that was a
thing for my dad because my mother got
to drive a cadillac i was like my woman
will drive a car line okay god bless you
yeah yeah they were never new
sure they were always used or evidence
or something
a couple of bullet holes yeah what was
your first car in l.a my first car so 93
we're talking yeah it had to be
something real shitty oh it was terrible
it was a it was a that was a luxury ford
escort oh my god they were never like
even knew they were no that's where you
find the body oh it's terrible this
little thing is if you if you want to if
you want to stop and your brakes go out
you just turn on the air conditioner
no power
but yeah i got that when i went out
there friend of mine gave me that so it
was a free car
when i got out there god damn it the
last car i had on long island i bought
for my brother never buy a new car it's
the worst thing you could do
yeah so i bought uh and never buy a car
for my brother because you can
overcharge
i don't remember that yeah i bought an
85 turbo coupe to thunderbird
yeah five speed you know that was my
comedy okay i put almost 200 000 miles
on that car because doing comedy like i
said i pick up the headliners here in
the city and this is this is how i work
because i pick up the headliners we go
to a shitty bar then you're supposed to
drop them off back at the improv
but i'm like you're going to take a cab
you're going to get out of a car to get
into a car oh you're already here let me
save you the cab there and i would drop
them off at home
i was always clean i was on time i
always opened for him and kept to my
time i wasn't dirty and i didn't ruin
the room for them so they would comics
wouldn't work that's great yeah yeah no
headaches easy no [ __ ] i'm on time
it's all good and i get a ride home so
that that's how i worked and that was
the car that 85 turbo coupe so i guess i
get my first tv deal to move out to l.a
and i'm like you know i'm thinking i'm
laying in bed thinking at night
you know what maybe i'll drive right i
get up in the morning i put the key in
the car everything goes wrong fluids
fall out tires fall off it's like
sunroof basically the car going i ain't
going yeah yeah yeah
get an airplane ticket so that was the
move you didn't go out to l.a until you
got your first tv deal how many no i did
go out i went out to do
tv i went out to do i think i wanted to
do tonight show or something okay so i
went out to do that and i went into the
city to do stand-up but i didn't go in
right away because i knew there was a
difference between long island comics
and city college yeah that's what i'm
trying i'm trying to get there still is
now yeah it's like still like there's
like a i'm trying to get an image of
that so you guys really didn't do the
running around in new york city no not
until because i knew i'm only gonna get
one shot of making an impression you
know and i knew that i was not not that
i wasn't ready but i wanted to uh be
extra ready yeah i wanted to make sure
all the uh the t's are across and eyes
are dotted this is my best shot
so i would do uh the road and the
difference is we're very animated the
long island comics we were actually
performative rather than like your back
up against the wall
we had we had bigger stages so we would
use [ __ ] there's voices and it was more
like like you said a performance so i
realized when i came into the city just
to watch wow okay these are like set up
punchline segway setup
so i got
started doing stand-up new york carrie
hoffman when he ran it gave me the late
night to host
because you know the checks were coming
out so you wanted you know yeah
performance you got to tap dancing yeah
so i got to do that so i got i got i
went pretty much went to school just
hosting because if i could just keep
people from talking loud it was a good
job
but i would see all the comics and i
would go in early and watch all the guys
you know jon stewart and all those guys
work and hey it was like going to school
so then my agent uh put together a
showcase at caroline's
okay i gotta go do the showcase i'm
ready i i did the caroline showcase uh
and i had a great set i walk off stage
estee
stand right there
hello come here you come here i want you
to work my club you come down come down
to the comedy cellar i want to i give
you a spot i want you to see you at the
club and i'm like oh okay jumping up and
down i'm trying to play it real cool
yeah i really think i really think i
peed a little bit
[Laughter]
she gave me a 220 spot
i went down she gave me a 220 spot and i
was happy to get it down there and i
just and i remember thinking to myself
all right this is this is if i'm going
down i'm going down both guns blazing
i'm going down swinging that's it yeah
i'm gonna die this is it this is it i'm
gonna die with a sword in my hand yeah
yeah yeah hell a gunfire i'm not gonna
try and be this so i walk on stage and
boom i had a great set nice manny was
alive and manny shook my hand it was
crazy i think i don't know if no one was
there but but i remember
that
flying home boys it was sure yeah yeah
yeah yeah you just feel that when you're
a kid and and to this day i just
just i still have a big spot in my heart
of course that's amazing god damn it
that's so [ __ ] cool damn 90s comedy
it's [ __ ]
not when you're going through it it's
nerve-racking anxiety but now i can look
back but then yeah just as [ __ ]
nerve-wracking as you guys know yeah
we've been successful for like three
months so it's still a little different
milk it
fine joy in it you [ __ ] what is it
august yeah
um all right i think we should get it
yeah
let's [ __ ] get it let us go oh okay i
will can i tell you one thing please i
want to hear it i thought of you guys
flying in here because i pulled i didn't
know i pulled a garbage move i was told
by others oh no what'd you think i'm on
a plane i had something to eat
something's stuck in my teeth first
class when you first class no i the
extra leg room i got the cover okay
comfort yeah not the mint i was on
jetblue i'm like you want the bed to lay
down so we can [ __ ] you on the price
just give me the extra leg so i'm in the
and i like either 6a or 6f because it's
the bulkhead and everything yeah yeah
yeah oh i got it all planned wait what's
that mean what six eight row six yeah
six a and six no one in front of there's
no one in front of you oh okay i got you
i'm with you
you're the first of the commoners you're
not one of the guys that has to do the
emergency thing though are you use the
door right there they think i'm gonna do
it yeah yeah they got kicked out of that
you did yeah why why why do you think
adam
what are we doing here
because he's too strong
hey sir you're too powerful sir we don't
want you embarrassing the other
passengers when you're saving
everybody's lives so we're in we're in
that seat me and my girlfriend man right
dude it was brutal i think we were
coming back from hawaii or something
like that last christmas and
i called a guy over like can i get can i
get a seat belt extender and he's like
oh
he's like unfortunately you can have the
seatbelt extended but we're gonna have
to move you because we can't have
someone who needs a seat belt extender
in the emergency
row yeah you're not able i'm not able
you're less able you can pin me what do
you mean you're not able here's the
worst part well it gets stuck in the
door then no one else can get out yeah
yeah but i called it i clog up the claw
sure
depressurize the cabin
but nobody can get out if we have to
land here's the worst part guy makes an
announcement to the entire plane would
anybody mind switching with this
gentleman we need able-bodied men to be
able to operate he said able-bodied
these two [ __ ] heroes behind me go i
have no problem doing it
they're like [ __ ] jacked
like to my girlfriend well you got to
blow these two guys i'm sorry
something's got to happen yeah yeah we
got a couple of patriots yeah
and dude she was my [ __ ] just got in
there put the seatbelt extended on ask
for an extra bag of cheez-its
[ __ ] tough luck all right so you're
flying over i'm sitting there right and
i get uh i get something stuck on my
teeth
and i'm like trying to
i look down there's the air sick bag
now the top of the air has the twisty
tie yeah the foil i ripped the twisty
tie thing off and i'm like and it's long
it's here i don't know i'm just sitting
there minding my own business just got
it
the lady sitting next to me opens up her
bag takes she's got a case like a james
bond cigarette case he opens it up
individually wrapped you know the uh the
floss thing sure great she takes one out
closes the case puts it back leans over
to me doesn't ask me just went take this
ah take this
okay that's damn good yeah i got it see
the real trash moves the fingers the
finger now yeah yeah i don't have the
finger my father used to use a matchbook
yeah
yeah they all damn
normal yeah yeah so you're at your
girlfriend's house when i uh
yeah
i'm [ __ ] digging in there
yeah that's tough steak was a little
tough
to do
all right so we're gonna play a little
rd garbage here we're gonna ask you a
series of questions to determine whether
you're trash or not um i don't know the
old school factor so far i give you a
little bit of a pass on that all right
so far
all right um
they don't still do you guys don't sell
on the house that you grew up in right
now what was the name of the street that
that that was on blue bird lane
pretty nice that's americana right
americana bluebird it's apple pie fourth
of july it's bye-bye
we're over there on bluebird lane now
yeah behind the walt whitman mall so you
got it it's right behind the mall off of
jericho turnpike nice what was the name
of the grocery store that your mom went
to uh
pathmark
not bad it's all right
there was a sea town too we'd go there
see towns are dice sea town kid depends
on
it depends on the seat town same with
key foods king cullen remember king
cullen yeah yeah i've i've never been
but i hear a good thing
there's still a couple floating around
right now
there are no there are for sure where do
you go now
what is your wife call now whatever
those boxes show up at the [ __ ] house
oh that's
nice yeah she shows up with instagram uh
the uh instacart thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah but there's a vons that i go to for
water and stuff and a ralph's i go to
the rouse and the bond okay and then
there's but you know there's only
certain things that she needs at the
whole foods so then you got to walk in
there that's the first answer we've
gotten where it's all the words delivery
that's pretty close yeah
that's real close okay okay i got a wife
okay and so do you it's coming your way
sure no she does it she gets her stuff
i'm an animal i'll go to the corner
store and get my my if the wife brings
you up in classiness that's just the way
it goes you picked her yeah it counts
yeah i i didn't pick her i just said i
gotta lock this up before she changes
her mind yeah of course she sees me
picking my teeth with a matchbook
is that an asstic bag
all right are you guys currently a shoes
off household or shoes on shoes off
right when he's on my wife's shoes off
yeah the wifey shoes okay nice i gotta
walk and take the shoes though okay what
if you have company do they take their
shoes off if you're not gonna take their
shoes off yeah yeah she says would you
mind taking the shoes off yeah
thank you
we want you to be comfortable
you want you to relax yes do you have a
hard time having people come back to the
house after you make them take the shoes
off they usually come back because they
forget their [ __ ] shoes
i got halfway home what the [ __ ] you
make me take your suitcases
my socks are wet
we had because we were taught we had
palmitario and we asked him we're like
if you go somewhere and they ask you to
take your shoes off we're gonna take
your shoes off i'll do it and then we go
oh yeah why because i ain't going back
there you go
they get one and i ain't going back
there you go i got a palmettory for you
too all right do well your friends do
well mm-hmm you guys are great if you
guys go out to dinner right all right
you
kevin j whoever you're going to dinner
with
what are we doing are we splitting the
check one he is taking turns what's
going to happen at some point they're
good friends if like we went out to
dinner get okay i'm gonna say i gotta go
bathroom excuse me
then i'm gonna go over to the server i'm
gonna listen i don't wanna fight with
these guys you take this all right you
give yourself a nice comeback you bring
it to me already ran yeah it's already
done
so it's already finished so i know this
and so you run it right now i'm going to
go to bed and come back i'm going to
sign it
all right anything else gets headed you
just okay
so it's done there's no fighting that's
pretty close to class that's pretty good
man that's good i like it
that's right no splitting to the check
none of that [ __ ]
i like it yeah and and then then if
you're out with another 10 he's going to
get mega you're making me look oh yeah
i want to win
i
that's another generational difference
too kids go out now they're well i just
had this or i just had that i remember
my uncles and my dad like fighting over
yeah and if one of them did do that mike
what are you doing why why would you do
that and then trying to give them the
cash yeah yeah and it just it's just
different yeah i'll tell you what's
scary is when you're out with like
hitters yeah sure when you're out we're
like people are like
man no i've been at a table and they
play credit card roulette oh that scares
the [ __ ] out of me oh jesus oh you mean
when it's like a monster bill it's like
oh geez everybody puts it in everybody
yeah and everybody can really afford it
but you yeah like you can pay the bill
but it's gonna it's gonna leave a mark
hoes oh yeah they put all the credit
cards in there
i went to a steakhouse one time for a
bachelor party
and it was everybody was doing what like
i was obviously
the that was a strong like five years
ago super struggling i probably had
about 150 bucks in my bank account right
i went up i ordered like a 40 filet and
i'm like all right well this is all i'm
having they start going shots let's do
shots there's like rounds of 15 shots
two rounds and i'm just sitting there
i'm like i'm gonna have to be the guy to
be like how can you put but one of my
buddies being the gentleman that he was
knew i was hemmed up right sure i was
like i got me kevin and whoever yeah
just do that that's okay i'll pay you
back
yeah i'll take four shots of strength
you know what i do when i was on the
road and i was like
i'd be in florida and i'd find the
timeshare
seminars because they gave you the free
lunch and i would get dressed up and i
would sit just for the free lunch and i
would sit for the timeshare seminars and
i would just eat take the card hang on
dude
put a check mark
on that one that's a wrap straight right
through jesus christ oh yeah the
timeshare hustle sitting there just
having shoes on i'm interested in buying
a property yeah
did you ever get caught up in any of the
uh any of the the fun things in the 80s
you ever do hands across america
no
go to live aid
i watched it he watched it i watched it
i worn out live that wasn't that live
aid what about a fight at uh you ever
get into a fight at yankee stadium or or
chase stadium or anything like that i
got into i avoided a fight at chase
stadium in loge
we were watching a mets
and there was a guy sitting there going
[ __ ] strawberry [ __ ] strawberry my
girlfriend time leaned over we go we're
leaving wise this guy's got another half
an inch yeah yeah punching somebody
right now yeah yeah [ __ ] strawberry
there was a guy next to him and then
like boom just start out but you can see
it you can see it oh it's yeah you can
read it and it's it's it's like you know
so it and and the noise at shea stadium
would bounce off the the upper that you
know you would sit there and so it's
almost like thunder dome yeah it's
something we got to get out of it it's
frightening yeah that was frightening
the vet was frightening in philly
they have a jail at the they had a jail
we talk about all the time i remember
being a little kid going to the vet and
being i thought i was going to fall off
of the stadium that's how [ __ ] narrow
it would like the seats were up up in
the nosebleeds i thought i was gonna
fall off of it this shea was a dump when
the beatles played there they put no
money in now
crazy what was your first concert
oh my first concert was south side
johnny in the asberry jukes at the
westbury music fan i'm gonna have to
give you a streak
too many words that was too many words
the only reason i went is because my
cousin took me i was a kid i don't know
what the hell i was looking at jeez yeah
asbury johnny south side johnny and the
asberry jukes
they they played with springs i didn't
even know what the hell i was looking at
my cousin took me to the westbury museum
you want to go ma can i go i know i just
wanted to get out of the house and i
went that's [ __ ] fantastic
mom's favorite singer i assume was
sinatra sinatra all right it's pretty
classy my father was elvis father was
elvis yeah my fault my father wanted to
be classy you ever see kiss in concert
no but i was a member of the kiss army
uh the first
checkpoint i was remembered i was
unraveling i had the stickers kiss on me
come on he starts talking about mustangs
you know you want to remember to kiss
zombies no why not you didn't send away
you didn't get alive too yeah that's
fantastic kiss alive he's one of the
greatest albums
of course it is of course i got alive
too
yes
kiss from the columbia record and tape
club that's the only one i didn't sell i
was gonna ask you did you do the
columbia house thing where you're
ripping i used to do columbia house and
then when they wouldn't send to my
address i put my name on the neighbor's
address yeah yeah and they would send it
to the neighbor's address and then you
go to the tri-county flea market and you
sell them
except for you were flipping them what
you were then flipping them
[Music]
you wouldn't do that
no wait i listened to them that columbia
what the [ __ ] were they thinking
somebody got fired for that it had to it
had to be like the world's biggest tax
deduction just
lost yeah yeah could have yeah it could
have been i mean because you know what
your neighbor when you have like you
know those little stuff this is a candle
shop there's two candles there with dust
on them they'd never sell a [ __ ]
candy yeah yeah yeah that type [ __ ] yeah
any magicians in your family
um
no i've seen a couple uncles disappear
oh that was beautiful
um anyone in your family ever involved
in a class-action lawsuit yeah i got
money
what i got money because my father took
uh actos or something he took some kind
of diabetes medicine okay
yeah like one of those people you were a
victim of sure the mesothelioma yeah
whatever that is you know nice you know
vaginal mesh yeah vaginal mess is big
nowadays
does anyone in your family say the word
idea
idea yeah i got a good idea no a deer
now
you know my aunt jerry used to go would
say looker
that would be yeah it's like a looker
look at
looka i don't never knew what that was
do you uh and jared do you have any
aunts or uncles that you don't call them
by their first name yeah what are they
uh i had i had i had a uh a guy we used
to call uncle scratch uncle scratch that
counts yeah yeah that would qualify
as not a government name yeah yeah that
that wasn't cool
what did he do for a living there's far
nothing as far as you know
any of your goddamn business you're
gonna get me in trouble slap the
microphone away i knew what is wrong
with you toby hit delete nobody was a dj
or something yeah
milk with dinner growing up as a kid
yeah
milk with the italian food would that be
with that with that fly milk no milk
with the italian food i don't think we
had because we had the cheese but if you
had like you know like a swanson hungry
man during a week or something shout out
to him man you like the swanson oh do i
ever gino's pizza rolls oh of course we
get the gino's we're allowed to have the
gino's pizza rolls that that's when you
knew mom was tired just
put in the pizza rolls in the toaster
oven yeah so you get that and you get uh
and you have a glass of milk with that
but you never really had milk with the
big pasta meal once on sundays okay did
you guys do the seven fishes at
christmas yeah you did yeah yeah yeah
they gotta get into heaven they sin all
do you still do that now my mother
doesn't my mother have some tuna i'm not
cooking
i'm not cooking get a fish fillet i used
to love the linguini and clam sauce my
mother would make linguine my mother
used to make her own
a
pasta
thing well my grandma my nana was alive
this one you want to eat
i'm not hungry but you guys can eat yeah
it was a chrome uh it would clamp onto
the bottom of the table yeah crank and
they put wax paper out i'll get it they
put wax paper out and then um the flour
going to wax they take the dough and
they make it long and they would make
the raviolis
yeah
yeah and they make the bones they put
neck bones it was peasant food italian
peasants you put the neck bones surface
yeah that's right
and the flavor and then for some reason
a hard-boiled egg went in the sauce some
sicilian thing yeah some curse thing if
you don't have it [ __ ] yeah yeah my
grandmother my great-grandma with the
two teeth she used to put a curse on the
mailman because he brought the bills
really
[Laughter]
what she tried to stop the mailman from
bringing the bills by giving him the
evil eye she would stand there in a
house dress this broad's checking out on
my own yeah that's pretty good yeah
he's bringing the bill it doesn't work
that way i stop him okay
hmm
do you buy stuff at the duty free shop
i don't really travel international that
much anymore okay so
at the house now you gotta you gotta you
have the garage we just talked about
that got the garage you got the garage
fridge
got a fridge in the garage oh i got a
fridge in the uh not in the garage i got
i got it out out in the back it's not in
the garage because i got an outfit
i got an outdoor friend classy wait a
minute hold on the house
it's an outdoor fridge no it's out my my
bedroom's here and then there's a little
like
closed in kind of thing terrace there's
a fridge out there yeah really full size
no the little what's in there little
odds water in there
uh i think there might be an edible or
two it's pretty classy
yeah and then you get the fridge in the
garage with the with the sodas and stuff
in there you do have that not now my
mother's house i don't have it in my
house yeah
at your mom's house i didn't marry an
italian boys okay yeah what's she what's
her i married a benetton ad she's
everything really
german scottish irish mexican uh
yeah american indian
not enough for a casino
trying to wet my beak over i try to do
something like hey maybe we can
uh yeah so she's everything and she grew
up in san francisco so a lot of the
stuff that i did yeah they don't fly yes
it's two different worlds pretty classy
having them she's fancy too
yeah she likes furniture from the stores
not trash night keep away on the
sidewalk what are you doing
[Music]
okay have you ever been to a red lobster
yeah
like it
now yeah i'll still go on the road okay
i'll go to a red lobster you can get
that shrimp do we have a summer house
second property i know you got the place
in new york i got the apartment here but
i got the apartment there's no summer
house like year-round yeah and i got it
for summer
do you keep your batteries in the
refrigerator
no i used to keep my keep cigarettes
yeah you bulked by the cigarettes you
put them in a refrigerator freezer
fridge yeah and then you make the uh
that in the refrigerator and then did
you guys have ice pops when you were a
kid of course all right [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're talking about the twin pops you
can crack them the twin part yeah crack
the twin pipe but then my mother would
make them oh yeah oh sure the ice tray
with the saran wrap and the toothpick
100 yeah frozen orange juice 100 yeah
um
have you has anybody in your family ever
won anything
lottery atlantic city atlantic city of
course no lotteries what was the biggest
score that you that was there was there
ever a big score that everybody knew
about other than just a jackpot type
thing not the government you [ __ ]
what are you trying to do what are we
doing um yeah
i i talked to my pop once because we hit
i never got a number
we hit what did you do ah they don't
build those places because they think
i'm gonna win here you know so yeah yeah
but yeah there was never any like you
know
my nephew was never standing there with
a big chick okay there was no guy never
anything like that i like it i like it
have you ever written your name in wet
cement yeah yeah all the time yeah all
still yeah really if i see it really if
i on a job we used to do it when you
when you put stuff on a job
they ever forget you anywhere when you
were a kid
uh
no but i hated my father's station wagon
wants to go to work with them so it's
not like they forgot me i never forgot
me anyway but they uh my father would go
drive from long island to queens and i
wanted to go to work on my dad so i
would hit i hid under the seat once
uh-huh and by the time he hit the uh
the time he hit the bridge what the what
are you doing here i'm going to work
daddy oh my god so yeah so now they
never left me that's great
[Music]
okay let me ask you guys something sure
did you ever uh sleep in the car on the
back window on the back deck you were
little could you sleep
i don't think
we had a van when i was that little
mm-hmm so that that wasn't a possibility
but i remember crawl i remember getting
up there i'm like yeah yeah mom's like
92 tauros sure long road trip long road
trip long road trip what they would do
they dropped the seats put the sleeping
bags in there and you were just snug it
in there so you can look out the top of
the back window oh that's cool what kind
of car this was a
it had to be like an 81 datsun we drove
from you're laying down in 81 dots
upstate pennsylvania right from there we
drove to dallas texas to see my cousins
jeez in that yeah how many of you earned
an 81 dots there was four of us and
you're laying down we're laying down the
back seats came down my mom and dad in
the front seat me and my brother
snuggled in the back seat and i remember
there was trash bags and
luggage all around us oh my gosh like we
were we were stuffed in there yeah i
still don't understand the physics of
vulgar i don't need to be honest with
you i would sleep when you added luggage
in trash bags that was out we would one
here and then you would put the armrest
which was this big yeah and my my
brothers were small so they could they
could fit either way okay on that side
with the heads
i like it yeah and then you always make
believe you were asleep so someone would
carry you in your pajamas yeah we were
just talking about that was top notch
yeah i'm a grown man i make my wife do
that and
[Laughter]
so you gotta earn your keep this camera
you never you never felt more safe or
slept better in the back seat of a car
when like your dad or your uncle or
something yeah just driving it yeah ac
on the smell of cigarettes yeah maybe
some talk radio on yeah and you were
hearing [ __ ] in the morning about
something just in the back knocked out
yep
sorry no please what do you drive now
uh i have a 1990 ls 400 which was the
first year lexus came out with the ls400
i murdered it all out which means it's
all black i took out the lights i put in
the they're called euro lights they're
clear lights uh i get black wheels i
dropped it down i smoked out the windows
and i drive around santa monica like the
yakuza
[Laughter]
i have that and i got my wife's got a a
little e-class mercedes nice very nice
very nice kid's doing all right i like
it
brush your teeth in the shower
until my wife said that's jeremy and i
can't do it anymore the answer is yes
what about peeing in the shower
not as far as you know
[Laughter]
she's listening yeah i like it
oh sorry is there a painting of the
family in your home now a painting
painting no but my my father okay this
is actually uh a thing in my house my
father we had that big cathedral ceiling
with the red rugs
and you know
welcome to beefsteak charlie's you know
kind of thing and my father got a
painting of my mother
he said you know i don't know he went
down to the he went down to the barber
shop there was a guy that had painted
that's awesome and made my mother sit
for this and she's got a painting of my
mother and it's like one of where the
eyes follow you
so now it's too much and it's hanging
right now because they sold the house
and my mom's in one of those 55 and over
communities sure so there's this giant
painting in her condo kitchen that fills
the wall yeah and it's her that's
awesome yeah
i told my wife i said i'm i'm getting
that painting when they when when she
goes we're not putting it in the house
my father got that i got to keep it i
got to at least keep it till i die
that's good stuff you garden now you
guys have a garden i didn't i didn't
garden men no nothing no garden no
gardening okay
have you had poison ivy as an adult
as an adult because that's a bad look if
you did yeah you're doing something
wrong if you're not you're not a
landscaper yeah now
i don't think i had it as i had as a kid
all the time yeah and we used to get
poison oak oak and sumac
i don't know anybody ever had it there
was a there was a theory that some kid
in the neighboring school died from it i
got them all i got every single one of
them i had a senior week i got it down
to shore i had poison ivy all over my
face down the beach no idea how do you
get poison ivy on a beach i'm telling
you i have no idea we drove from we
literally left after graduation we got
in the car we drove down the shore woke
up the next day my whole face was
covered in poison ivy did you drive
through the woods no i have no idea i
had to go to the hospital and get a shot
jesus
brutal mark that down
how many pillows on the bed
how many pillows how many pillows do you
sleep with like you got the nice pillows
you put everything inside oh you can't
use the nice pillows will show you
kitten not the nice pose uh i got i got
one of that little rolly thing that half
moon pillow okay and then i got i got
one old shitty pillow that she's dying
to throw out oh yeah yeah it's got i
think it still has feathers it's this
soft little thing that i don't get rid
of so i'll go with one and a half two if
you want to mark it not one between your
legs no not one holding one i do i i
dislocated this shoulder okay i got one
here too
yeah
fan on you while you sleep i would like
one but one for the breeze and the noise
but we don't have it the white noise is
pretty cool you know what i used to get
used to the old shitty air conditioner i
had when i was a kid
because it would go
then it would drop a gear boom
now oh
now it's getting cold
and the noise is going to keep the
monsters away
i need something to drown out the fear
baby yeah um
are you currently in a beef with a
neighbor
in in california no in california out
here in my apartment building they know
not to come near me because really why
is the thing it's the middle i'm gonna i
got an apartment here right it's four
o'clock in the morning
i got up and i just i'm half asleep
boom boom boom guy opens the door and i
just i turned it to my father my eyes
dropped and i went you want to lower
that place
do you want to lower that and the guy
went okay older guy younger guy you're
like a younger kid yeah younger yeah
younger kid
but yeah in in
you know not in l.a
i don't know who my neighbors are yeah i
know what they name their wi-fi that's
what i know
[Laughter]
and that's good enough for me i don't
need to know any more than that
um
what's the fridge situation at the house
in
california what do you got i got one
fridge in the kitchen stainless steel
yeah she's got a stainless fridge double
opens this way yeah one of these nice
yeah i got that i like it and i got that
little one you have the little one yeah
the little one it's class it's nice
i think i got it at a radio station to
be honest with you which one
that's kind of trashy i got to be honest
what's the range viking what are we
looking at what the range the stove it's
gas i don't know who the hell okay
i know i know i paid for it that's all
right is there an island in the middle
of the kitchen yes statin
yeah she's got the island you got the
island yeah i got the island very nice
how many cars how many car garage
well one's well it's three-car garage
but i don't have any cars in there but
you got three-car garage but there's one
of them and there's one of them in the
studio one of them is the studio yeah
one of them is that that you guys were
in pretty sharp man
pretty sharp
look at you we don't know
i i yeah i mean i kind of do have you
ever been ghost hunting
i'm a grown man okay i'm just asking
just asking adam i'm trying to get i
wasn't brought here for this
yeah no i've never been have you seen a
ghost
no i also a grown man i don't think so i
don't what does that mean
my grandmother's basement you know when
you're scared to go in the basement when
you're a kid there's definitely ghosts
down there let's be honest you know so
my grandmother had a place in queens
there was a basement down in it and the
boiler room was down and you know and my
father could always make the boiler work
in the hot water heater so he'd have to
buy a new one wait smack it with
something i come down and hold the tool
so i would go down there you know he had
the light and everything so once he
forgot something down it goes down to
the boiler room and i got the [ __ ]
scared
yeah to go get whatever he forgot wrench
or whatever it was
um and i went down and it was done it
was like the boilers making noises and
[ __ ] so it wasn't like you know
there was something there that scared me
sure yeah
i thought of it yeah it felt scary i got
the chills there's only one way to leave
a basement that's sprinting up the steps
that's it
have you ever saved a cigar box for
storage [ __ ] yeah i still got them yeah
yeah i still got it yeah yeah artero
fuente chateau naturales i know
yeah yeah there's like your passport and
a book of matches in there yeah yeah
yeah there's baseball cards in there too
but i'm not throwing this away maybe one
day that's like an uncle's purple heart
yeah that's fantastic jerry grody card
the old catcher for the mets ed crane
pool
huh yeah i got that i got um
i have a 1933 world's fair can opener i
got my grandfather died damn i got i
took it before my cousin yeah yeah
that's how i got it yeah yeah that's in
there
it was a run on the bank before they
fleeced the place yeah uh this is a this
is a andrew schultz inspired question
dad what's your watch situation like
my phone i don't have a wall yeah i
watch anybody don't do watches i
underwater i'm gonna say any jewelry
other than the wedding ring this is my
wedding and this ring my my mother gave
to my father when they got engaged oh
wow and when he died uh i took the ring
and now uh that's my wedding ring nice
but that's it that's only because i
don't i don't like [ __ ] hanging on i'm
in the same way i'm gonna wear a wedding
ring no no yeah i bought one for like
nine bucks the night before we got
married and i was just like i'm never
gonna wear this
does your wife get angry at you no she
doesn't care again yeah all right um
yeah no that's that jewelry situation
for me even the wife doesn't you know
yeah she's got it
he said that with a little reservation
she's got it i got it i got it for her
she's got it i don't even wear it why am
i
um all right i got two from the patreon
let's do it all right so guys as you
know when you're doing the patreon we
will ask your garbage question on the
air
um this one's from brian
i uh my question is do you or anyone in
your family walk with a limp
i did yeah i did i did for what
uh i just when i when i was born one of
my legs had to catch up to the other one
really really and it settled itself out
yeah well i got it you know i had a lift
in my shoe really so yeah but yeah wow
you don't still have it though what no i
got i got the uh uh i still got the
little bit of the lift really nice
not nice birth defects
[Laughter]
what other injuries did you have when
you were a kid yeah i broke my wrist
three times doing what once i fell off
you know that boat that we had in the
back he fell off of that trying to pick
a flower for my mother for mother's day
bang we're in the emergency room uh once
i fell off the fence uh levittown my my
my cousin scotty lived right by the
schoolyard so you could it was a big
fence nine ten foot fences jumping
fences
every some kid of every group always
gets her company but every every like it
was always in the summer and i always
started the school year with a cast yeah
so yeah you ever save any of the casts
after you got it for a while and then
the smell would you because people sign
them they would always say
especially in the summer yeah
and then you get to hang it don't use
the hanger i'm using a freaking hanger
i would use a roller i would get in with
yeah
yeah so yeah we'd save them for a while
and then you go because you know your
friends signed them and sure yeah
then then you got the cats where you
couldn't sign like the colorful ones
yeah yeah like they were always real
fancy they were like the kids when they
got the i didn't glow in the dark ah
[ __ ] what
i was in a cast for like two years my
whole
power shooting accident
two years ago yeah it's just what the
bone wasn't healing they were like oh
they just kept trying on your arm
um
but they were like if it doesn't work
well i'll try certain they end up having
to have surgery but i just kept i had to
get a new cast every like six weeks for
like 18 parts
yeah so they were like hey we got it
were you like were you like one of the
early adopters yeah let's see if this
works worst thing i was 25.
i was at parties with chicks like yo
turn the lights off but that's like the
kids that when they had braces they got
the colored rubber bands oh yeah
never had
braces no no no no no i had that apply i
mean we talked about that that appliance
it's like the it puts a knife brace no
it was a it was a metal bar that ran
from side to side across the roof of
your mouth and then your mom would have
to put a key in there and turn it get
the [ __ ] out it's like medieval it's
called a pallet expander crazy and it
push you literally feel your skull
cracking open every time oh my god you
gotta turn it every day for like six
months or something
come here let me wind your face dude
yeah it was a [ __ ] scene i was a real
cool kid i don't know if you're picking
up on that yikes uh i got one more from
the patreon and then we can call it uh
this is from sideshow bub anyone in your
family ever held back a grade
yeah really yeah you no brothers uh no
cousin cousin yeah held back a grade
what grade
i don't remember a kid you know i was
like he's a kid but yeah i here's the
thing with school i'm not going back
what do i got to do to get through this
yeah oh yeah i was the same way let me
get the [ __ ] out of me get out of here i
want to go to work i want to get out of
here yeah ladies and gentlemen mr adam
ferrari kippy what are you thinking
come on dad what italian garbage yeah
he's trash the kid's a long island trash
all the way i mean the boat is the the
the boat with the cadillac that's
genetic you can't come back from that
your kids are gonna have that
their kids are gonna have to live with
that cadillac with that became a pickup
truck yeah the lift in the foot not to
sound insensitive but that put you over
the top yeah yeah right there
defense that's beautiful defense yeah
yeah your uncle fishing in the
three-piece suit yeah yeah your mom
trying to make the the the macaroni on
the [ __ ] grill yeah still saying
you'd write your name in wet cement
you wouldn't do that if you had the
opportunity
you know you wouldn't break a stick off
and just go
i'm trying to i'm trying to be a
gentleman a y g baby
at ayg that's what yeah buddy thank you
so much for coming and sitting down with
us anything you got anything you want
the folks out there yeah
uh i will be at the chicago improv i
have hilarious in cleveland coming up uh
levity you guys are gonna be at my
goobies what tour schedule go to
adamferara.com the atom for our podcast
you can catch the episodes with both
these yeah
and fantastic thank you for having me my
friend thank you buddy i love what you
guys are doing thank you thank you this
was absolutely amazing it was absolutely
fun thanks for going over all the all
the comedy stuff that was
really cool that was fantastic what do
you got for him uh at cameron comedy on
all social media then you know uh
patreon.com youtube itunes uh there's
merch available and uh come check us out
on a live show gang we love you we'll
see you next week a peace